ban radio app
next a discussion on social and economic
issues facing white working-class
Americans authors JD Vance and Charles
Murray took part in this event hosted by
the American Enterprise Institute
it's an hour
good afternoon everyone good afternoon
I'm Carlin Bowman and I'm a senior
fellow here at AI and I'd like to
welcome all of you and our c-span
audience to the first Bradley lecture
program of this academic year as many of
you know who've attended these programs
in the past
they're usually lectures but with
tonight's event we saw a rare
opportunity to host a conversation about
a culture in crisis where as always
grateful to the Lions and Harry Bradley
Foundation of Milwaukee Wisconsin for
making this possible midway through this
extraordinary memoir hillbilly elegy JD
van says that working as a cashier at
the local grocery store where he lived
turned him into an amateur sociologist
as he watched what people bought how
some people gamed the system and how the
owners treated customers differently he
says at that point he began to read
books about social policies such as
William Julius Wilson the truly
disadvantaged and Charles Murray's
losing ground
he writes that both of these books were
written about African Americans but
could just as easily have been written
about his family and neighbors he
realized that no expert or single book
could explain their problems
mr. Vance's description is much more
than a mature sociology it tells us what
goes on in the daily lives of real
people and here I'm quoting him directly
when the industrial economy goes south
he continues it's about reacting to bad
circumstances in the worst way possible
it's about a culture that increasingly
encourages social decay instead of
counteracting it in this he echoes the
concerns of many at AEI over the years
including among others the late Robert
Nesbit who wrote the quest for community
in 1953 Peter Berger in the late Richard
John Newhouse who wrote a short but
influential AI pamphlet in the 1970s
about the importance and the fragility
of the country's mediating institutions
families neighborhoods and communities
and of course to my current colleagues
Nick Evers debt and charles murray among
others taken together JD Vance's
hillbilly elegy in Charles Murray's
coming apart
offer vivid portraits of our country a
country where millions of people live by
JD's grandparents code of self-reliance
and hard work well mill that millions of
others don't and they have lost touch
with the virtues that give our lives
purpose and direction and ultimately
make us happy you will be able to
purchase copies of copies of mr. Vance's
book after this conversation and he's
graciously agreed to sign them we will
do so after hear after the conversation
and we invite you to join us for a
reception in the gallery outside mr.
Vance will begin tonight's conversation
about why he wrote hillbilly elegy and
the reaction to it JD thank you well
thank you thank you guys for having me
Charles thank you for being willing to
do this hopefully I don't I don't worry
after an hour and a half but so so the
question of sort of why I started to
write this book is that I was a third
year law student at Yale and I was you
know listening to the same conversation
that folks were having all across the
country about open mobility and
inequality and I was trying to sort of
understand why it was that kids who grew
up like me were so under represented in
places like Yale and it wasn't just a
sort of economic thing I recognized that
I was a cultural outsider so people at
Yale talked about things that just
didn't make any sense to me so how they
would make 160 thousand dollars a year
but they didn't think that it would be
enough because they would have to send
their kids to some fancy daycare in
Manhattan and I thought what is what are
these people talking about who are these
aliens and why are they the ones who are
at Yale Law School and nobody like me is
so the more that I thought about why it
was that kids like me were really
underrepresented at these sorts of
places I started to think that it
implicated not just something about my
own life or my family's life but also
something that was much more broadly
shared across our neighborhood across
our community and as the title of the
book suggests across our culture and so
the more that I you know researched the
more that I wrote the more that I
interrogated family members who
graciously offered to share their lives
and histories with me the more that I
realized that this was a very very real
and significant problem this wasn't just
something that was unique to yale law
school or to middle
ohayo it was unique to the entire white
working-class and as you've written
about I think two groups much broader
even than that so I started writing the
book at the end of 2013 I spent probably
two years writing it I was always
working full-time so it was always a
sort of nights and weekend endeavor and
the more that I wrote it the more that I
realized that there were hopefully some
new sociological or economic insights in
the book but what I really had to offer
was sort of explaining what it's like
when you grew up with these problems as
I write in the book hung around your
neck what it's like to actually grow up
in these communities what it's like to
be thrust into this very culturally
alien territorial IKEA law school when
you grow up like a working-class white
kid so that's the book that I set out to
write and I believe Carlin said
something about the reception and the
only thing I'll say about the reception
that I expected is that before the book
came out I told my wife that I really
just hoped that it wouldn't be so under
read that it would embarrass me and I
think that I I may be suffering from the
opposite problem now yeah but what we're
going to get to the deep serious topics
in a minute there are just a couple of
things I have to ask which is you are
really frank about the immediate members
of your family those of you who have not
read the book it is not a sociological
treatise thank god it is it is it is
deeply personal story very well written
I'd like to know where you learned to
write like that it can't be Yale and and
and the things he is telling about his
family get really personal and a lot of
them are not pretty and yet they agreed
to have their real names used in the
book that's right
so you're still getting along with
everybody still get along with everybody
yeah you know one of the things I tried
to do to sort of mitigate against the
fact that I was going to be airing our
family's dirty laundry so to speak is
make my family part of the writing
process and so it wasn't just sort of my
personal memory that informed the
writing it was also interviewing my aunt
my uncle my sister and so forth I think
because of that they felt like they were
part of the story like it wasn't just my
story but it was also theirs and so even
though it is like you said very frank I
think that people feel like it's
frank and honest but also said something
that needed to be said because one of
the things that happens when you grow up
in a family like this you grow up in a
community like this is that you're not
totally sure why you feel the way that
you do about certain things you're not
totally sure why you have the attitudes
that you have and I think my family
really appreciates that I sort of shed a
little bit of light on that but also put
it in an in a broader context I'm so
sorry
that is the first phone call I've gotten
all month I think I do not get phone
calls that was when he actually the the
the thing that struck me as I was
reading the book and by the way this
book is one which I read from beginning
to end which doesn't happen very often I
I'm going to be doing a panel on a book
so I read in it and I get the things I
need to get out of it but this one I was
just completely engrossed in but I was
especially engrossed because I am
scots-irish and I would put up my
lineage of scots-irish forebears against
yours in terms of of the they're there
as far as Americans go pretty clean
scots-irish blood they went to
Appalachia the same as your forebears
did they were in North Carolina a
classic place for them to be and then
another classic move they moved to
Missouri early in the 19th century there
are nothing like your people there there
are bits and pieces that that sound
familiar but the the culture did not
look recognizably like the one that that
you described furthermore I have had in
addition to writing about the white
working-class and coming apart I got to
say my experience isn't just as a pointy
headed intellectual I lived for the
first 18 years of my life in a town of
15,000 which did have an upper middle
class because we had a corporation there
but a lot of middle class a lot of
factory workers one high school one
junior high best friends were sons of
daughters a factory were
there's that was 18 years in the last 27
years I've lived in a little town rural
Maryland which is also middle-class
working-class farmers and a couple of
oddballs like my wife and me and my our
kids went to a working-class high school
and the town just down the road here
again I guess I can say I think with
some fairness that I've had I've been
rubbing shoulders with a white
working-class for a long time
bits and pieces I recognize from people
we know and specific events it looks
like you're describing a culture which
in your words is a hillbilly culture
which is distinct from all of those you
have spent the last several weeks I'm
sure getting people doing exactly what I
just did saying hey you know I have the
this is my experience can you give me a
sense of how as you look at the mosaic
of people telling you about the white
working-class now you piece this all
together yeah absolutely so first it's
it's a it's worth noting that if you
look at the ethnographic studies of this
area you find that the scots-irish are
disproportionately represented in this
area of the country so Eastern Kentucky
eastern Tennessee West Virginia Western
Virginia and so forth so there is
definitely a sort of ethnic component to
what's going on in a lot of these areas
one of the things that I think is
definitely true is that as these
scots-irish folks have migrated out of
Appalachia they've gone to Kentucky's me
they've gone to Indiana Ohio Michigan
and so forth because that's where the
industrial jobs were I think it's
probably fair to say that there's been a
lot of cultural intermixing so maybe
some of the divisions that I draw that
are very very stark and my family are
starting to disappear maybe they've
disappeared in generations past so there
is something where the white working
class culture is a lot more homogeneous
than just the scots-irish part of it but
I also think that because the
scots-irish part of it is the biggest
part of white working-class culture
there's a sense in which skychi
scots-irish and white working-class are
increasingly commingled and mean the
same thing so it's not necessarily that
my family's experiences or that the
things that I described is unique to
scots-irish culture are only
represented there but I do think that
there's something about that particular
part of America you know they're their
authors that say we should just call it
the United States of Appalachia it's
there's something to be said for the
fact that the scots-irish culture is
both unique and regionally distinct but
it's also spread pretty far and wide and
has had a lot of effect on other parts
of Americans yeah and and other authors
have written about the scots-irish
culture Jim Webb force born fighting and
the statistics on what ethnic group
contributes most to the American armed
forces it's the scots-irish absolutely
and I take great pride in this I've have
to point out that our leading
characteristics though which I learned
long before I read hillbilly elegy is
being drunk and violent but we've we
made great pioneers that's that's
perhaps because people couldn't stand us
so we had to keep moving west but I
thought you said your family wasn't like
mine oh well I've as I read in
scots-irish culture if that's what I
thought there was a lot of drunkenness
of course a lot of violence in it but
then I compare that to Fishtown the fish
town is the Philadelphia working-class
community in coming apart sure that I
use as the label for the statistical
characteristics have changed over the
last 50 years but there is also a couple
of really good books that have been
written about fish town one was a PhD
dissertation that I quote extensively in
coming apart and the other was an actual
published book that came out in the
1960s and the book that came out in the
1960s is really interesting because that
the way that is described is first a lot
of islands in that community but it was
mostly structured violence so that so
that when somebody came into the
neighborhood and and burgled a house
they might not bother to call the cops
but to take care of it they took care of
it in their own and personal disputes
were solved a lot of cases with fighting
there was too much spousal abuse to in
the community there was a lot of
violence there but the other thing that
is made clear and there was a lot of
hard drinking and fish down in the
nineteen
sixties the other things made clear is
that the community really functioned and
so people would say to the poverty
workers who came in that they liked
their community they were happy in their
community and it drove the poverty
workers crazy because these people
refused to recognize that they were poor
refused to recognize that they were
miserable to what extent does that fit
in or not fit in with the community you
knew of when you were growing up in the
1990s yeah well so the first thing I'll
say is that you mentioned not being
willing to call the police even if
people were maybe being a little violent
and it's funny my I was talking to my
sister a couple years ago and she knew a
family and Middletown where all the
Christmas gifts had been stolen
not not long before Christmas and the
person I think post about it on Facebook
or told her friends in some other way
and talked about how you know all of our
Christmas gifts are stolen we called the
police they're here everything's sort of
taken care of and the most common
refrain that they got from the responses
was why did you call the police why
don't you just handle it yourself and so
there's there's definitely this
willingness I think not just to
sometimes engage in violence but also an
unwillingness to engage in sort of you
know involving the broader community and
or involving some of the institutions of
community and that that violence to
answer your specific question how
similar is the Middletown that I grew up
in to Fishtown so it's similar in a lot
of ways but it's also much more
accelerated in its development right so
some of the things that maybe existed in
1960s Fishtown that you're writing about
is you know maybe 1990s Fishtown looks a
lot like 1990s Middletown I suspect the
answer is that it probably does and what
you find in these communities I think is
is one they're not extraordinarily
destitute right so if you go to
Middletown Ohio you look you drive down
the street you go to my old neighborhood
this is not hardcore poverty there were
definitely times in my life where we
fell below the poverty line no doubt
about it
but I never felt that we couldn't put
food on the table that we couldn't put
clothes on our back I always felt that
there was at least some sort of material
baseline maybe you know because the
social welfare state maybe because of my
grandparents will
you know well that they had accumulated
when they were able to have a
middle-income job so there is definitely
a refusal to recognize that you're poor
and one of the things I wrote about in
the book is that you know I'd built this
sort of construct in my mind between the
really poor white neighborhood in our
neighborhood which I just thought of as
sort of working-class and middle-class
and the older that I get and the more
that I think of Middletown and its
geography those neighborhoods weren't
actually that different
they weren't geographically that
different they weren't actually that
different if you look at the houses but
we had sort of built this thing in our
minds because I think people don't want
to think of themselves as poor and
there's definitely an element of pride
built into that right I mean one of the
things I write that's very distinct
about scots-irish culture is that we're
very proud we're proud of who we are
we're proud of our families and one of
those points of pride is you don't want
to tell strangers that you're poor how
about the differences you say that
physically in terms of housing stock the
two parts of town weren't that different
even at that time though did they see
themselves the people who lived in what
looked to you like the poor part of town
did they see themselves as living in a
different part of town from you it's
hard to say because I didn't obviously
have a ton of exposure to the you know
as a kid outside of my broad
neighborhood my sense is that no kid
that I went to school with even the kids
who were very clearly pretty destitute
that they did not expect that they were
poor they did not think of themselves as
especially impoverished you know there
definitely was a recognition that there
were rich people out there and some
Middletown has a very nice sort of upper
crust doctors and lawyers part of town
that's very distinct from the part of
town that I grew up in so there was some
recognition that there were rich people
out there and my grandma was very very
cognizant of the fact they were rich and
you know in some cases just like them
because of it but there there really
wasn't a sense that among the the lower
income or the working-class kids that
there was a lot of class division
between them I do I do think that people
really resented and and and weren't
willing to say look we're really poor
there was always there was this
recognition there was the rich there
were the hard-working middle-class folks
and the poor folks were
you know maybe somebody else but not us
okay
now let's turn to the labor market
because you have lots of different
interesting observations to make about
the labor market and this is one of the
great things about the book that you are
start out one of the narratives and you
think you know where he's going and then
all at once the next turn of events
takes you completely by surprise so in
one sense this is a classic William
Julius Wilson stuff that your
grandfather worked for the steel company
was at it that's right yeah
so it worked for the steel company we're
getting really good working-class wages
in fact he was close to six figures at
one point wasn't he yeah there's a point
where I write in the book where my
family and I'm talking specifically then
about my mom who worked in health care
and my stepdad who worked as a truck
driver
they probably they maybe didn't make
$100,000 a year you know I'm kind of
speaking as a kid in that part of the
story but they definitely I'm sure
earned a pretty solid middle-class wage
we had a what I thought was a nice house
we had you know two cars it wasn't that
we were again it's not that we were
destitute but definitely you know that
sort of Economic Security didn't last
very young and I think it didn't last
very long unfortunately not because of
the economy in our case but because of
some of the decisions they made well you
also have some interesting comments to
make about when you were working at
various kinds of menial jobs you know
the physical labor jobs and you talked
about one guy and was working with you
that would habitually take half hour the
bathroom breaks and when he did this so
frequently and it got to be a subject of
considerable amusement around the
workplace it got fired and at the point
he gets fired he is very upset because
my girlfriend is pregnant gonna have a
baby and why how can you be doing this
to me and no sense that he screwed up
and so take put together all of these
semi contradictory pieces of your your
observations of people in the labor
market whereby it is a weird combination
old-fashioned Protestant work ethic and
postmodern of victimization it's not my
fault what's going on there yeah
absolutely so that guy this was in a
tile warehouse that I worked at right
before I went to law school I was trying
to save up money for the the move to New
Haven and I remember every time he went
into the bathroom it got to the point
where me and another co-worker would
call out you know the time so 15 minutes
is a half an hour and it and it got it
got to the point where it was it was it
was literally two or three hours of the
day he was not on shift he was doing
something else I don't know if he had an
alcohol problem or what his issue was
via the 19 year old girlfriend she was
pregnant the guy who we worked for even
offered her a time or a job briefly for
a time working in some sort of
administrative role and the thing is he
made a pretty decent wage you know most
of the guys who worked at this tile
warehouse made $16 an hour which is
plenty to live at or live on in this
area of the country you started out at
$13 an hour that's what I made and it
occurred to me when this guy was
eventually fired that he didn't
recognize his own agency and the problem
at all he was it was not a made-up
feeling he was legitimately
extraordinarily angry at his boss for
firing him and thought that his boss had
done something wrong and that was really
really worrisome because you know people
have to recognize that they still have
some control over their own lives at the
same time you see guys like that kind of
coexist with people who are really
hardworking who are trying to find a job
and maybe they can't maybe they were
laid off from the steel mill at the age
of 45 and it's really hard for them to
reenter the labor force at anything like
a wage did they earn when they were a 45
year old steel steel mill worker and you
see both of these things happening
simultaneously and so when you're a kid
growing up in this environment it's hard
one not to recognize that you have the
really hard working people I'd say the
majority who just are trying to get
ahead I think the labor markets been
pretty tough on them and you have the
people who are not doing what they
should to try to get ahead and
importantly they don't recognize it they
don't recognize that they still have
some control over their own lives and
this is something that my grandma
when I think of you know a woman who
didn't even have a middle school
graduate education you know she left
Kentucky when I think she was 13 years
old she was incredibly perceptive you
know she's classic Blue Dog Democrat she
didn't believe that government didn't
have a role in helping the poor but what
she always told me was don't ever be
like those effing losers who think the
deck is stacked against him and she said
that as someone who recognized that for
some people the deck was stacked against
them and so there was this remarkable
perception about her where she could
simultaneously recognize that things
weren't always perfect but also say you
can't let yourself give in to the worst
defeatism that exists in our community
because then you're completely doomed
then you're like the kid who has a good
job at the tile warehouse but just
doesn't keep it generational here I mean
if you try to do a timeline of this are
the kids who think they have no moral
agency increasing and the ones who are
working hard under difficult
circumstances decreasing my sense is
that that's definitely true and you see
it in some of the statistics obviously
you see in the way that people were
dropping out of the labor force but you
also just and as I write about in the
book you see it in these communities
there was a very definite sense in the
place where I grew up that for more and
more people maybe their choices didn't
matter this is a very destructive
tendency that exists in these
communities again I don't think that it
exists completely out of nowhere you
know that's what's so hard about this
right is to sort of see the whatever you
want to call them structural barriers
maybe that life throws at you but then
to still try to overcome them anyway
that's really hard to do and
unfortunately I think very few were and
fewer kids are able to do it and so I
think consequently you see a community
that is really really struggling how
about marriage because you know but I
talk about coming apart and I'm trying
to convey to people how much things have
changed I go to marriage as being the
building block of communities it's the
prototypical institution of a free
society and then I cite the numbers
which are if we talk about non Latino
whites
ages 30 to 49 as of 1960 84% of them
were married and as of 2010 when I reach
for the numbers I used for coming apart
that was down to 48 percent which is
just I mean talk about a sociological
phenomenon of incredible magnitude right
that was it so when you were growing up
and also in to the extent you can look
back to previous generations
tell me about marriage in Middletown so
you know I saw very personally the sort
of statistics that you're describing
right so fewer and fewer people were
married I want to throw in another
statistic out at you which is that I
believe in Sweden which is the country
that has the second highest marital
partners or sorry maternal partners
it's 2.8 so the average kid will see
their mom in Sweden with 2.8 maternal
partners ok in the United States I think
it's 12 point 813 so we have this
unbelievable problem and of course
that's concentrated in the working class
you have this unbelievable problem not
just of the decline of marriage but the
decline of sort of home stability there
are two sides of the same coin but it's
important to recognize both sides of
that right so is marriage declining it's
it's definitely declining and I think
the really interesting question is why
is it declining why are so many fewer
people in this community getting getting
married and so one answer you might say
and I know a lot of critics of coming
apart would have said this is look you
know the industrial economy has gone
south created all these financial
pressures that exist in these
communities that didn't exist before
consequently people aren't getting
married as much I think that's a small
part of it but it's a small you know
part of it so if you think of for
example median wages right after
accounting for transfers median wages
have been on a sort of flat but slightly
upward curve that's a problem right but
it doesn't quite explain how we've gone
from 84 to 48% and I suspect lower
especially when we haven't seen anything
like the same trend among non
working-class people so you know the the
it's it's definitely there and it's
definitely happening and the really
difficult question I frankly don't
have a fantastic answer is why it's
happened okay you've got friends sure
that are now in their early 30s hmm
among the guys you know how many you
have roughly what percentage of them
have gotten married and stayed married
of the the folks who went and got an
education and either stayed in
Middletown to work or you know left
Middletown because there aren't a ton of
high-skilled jobs in Middletown most of
them you know off the top of my head I
can't think of one of my
college-educated friends who either
isn't married or engaged interesting you
know you're a small spot so maybe I'm
not remembering everybody it's a lot
another way it's it's it's a lot of
mingott so so every single one of my
groomsmen very similar story small town
Ohio went to college at Ohio State every
single one of them are either married or
engaged right now you think of the folks
who didn't get an education
maybe maybe stayed in Middletown or
stayed in similar circumstances it's you
again it's it's tough to think of a good
friend who has been married and stayed
married and one of the things you
definitely see in the working class is
that people get married sooner so I
definitely know of some folks who got
married but then the marriage didn't
necessarily last and so Wow it's a very
it's very stark because I can't I
honestly can't think of someone who
didn't go to college who I grew up with
in Middletown I think sorry any one one
person out there about the women that
you knew in high school what's happened
to them well you know my sense is that
from a purely social perspective not a
material perspective but from a purely
social perspective maybe the women are
doing a little bit better than the men
and part of that comes from the sort of
maternal cultural aspect that is very
much at the forefront of my book where
you have these women who a lot of times
when the men aren't working in the men
aren't taking care of the kids the women
have to step in they have to do the
things that a lot of the men aren't
doing and so it's it's not uncommon to
see in my community I write about my
cousin for example I think this is very
much her life story who have found
herself in a marriage that fell apart
very quickly but she had a young
baby and it was the baby that got her
life back on track because she had to
take care of that kid if she didn't take
care of the kid nobody else would and
you see that story a lot of women you
know when the family breaks down it's
very rarely the men in these communities
that are stepping up it's almost always
the women it reminds me of this
observation was made by one of the
people in Fishtown
and she was saying you go down the
street and you see this woman with a
baby in one arm and a couple of shopping
bags in the other and walking behind her
is a guy playing his video game and
there is a kind of demoralisation of
males using a polite word a forgiving
word that seems again of both a
combination of this what the statistics
say and a combination of what I've
observed in my own personal life there
are there is simply a falling away from
the old standards of hey I'm the guy
I've got to put food in the table I've
got to take care of my children because
that's what a real man does right an
incredible falling away from that and
even though I know you can't get me a
cut-and-dried answer as you think about
your friends can you come up with some
even quite specific reasons why they
have fallen away from that specific
reasons why they've fallen away from it
I mean you know one thing that comes to
mind is that there was definitely it's
sort of tangential but it is a bit
related there's definitely a culture of
masculinity in a lot of these
working-class neighborhoods that treats
schoolwork as a feminine and ever right
and that that's something that I've you
know I wrote about it it's it's a
demonstrable statistical phenomenon also
something that you see where you know if
you're doing really well in school which
of course I didn't do very well it's
school for a lot of my life but you see
kids you know use certain slurs I won't
repeat them in front of these polite
people but but definitely you hear
certain slurs directed
people who are doing well in school and
there's a sense that hard work in school
is a feminine endeavor but I think that
can very easily translate to hard work
and a lot of other life's endeavors
right my sense is that you know
psychologically the decline of the
industrial economy has been harder on
men than it is on on women and that
that's something that I'm just sort of
picking out of you know I don't have a
statistical yeah the basis in that but
my sense is that because there is such
pressure on young men you've got to be
you got to take care of your family
you've got to be the breadwinner that
when it disappears in some of these
working-class communities where that
ethic of sort of masculine self-reliance
is really strong that it's it's it's
very easy for the men to say well I
can't find a job and I'm not gonna
continue dealing with this psychological
impulse that makes it really hard on me
because I'm unemployed so you sort of
fall away from in different ways that's
that's you know again that's that sort
of conjecture I haven't thought a ton
about why men uniquely are struggling in
this particular world
yeah there's there are a variety of
other explanations to that I think often
don't get set as bluntly as they should
should get said and one of them is that
in 1960 the fact is that if you wanted
regular sexual access to a woman you
pretty much had to get married yes were
there other yeah birds was there sex
outside marriage sure but was it easy it
was it was it the same way it is now not
even close and insofar as 1920 21 year
old males really aren't yearning to
settle down and without any
encouragement that was a pretty powerful
incentive and if that incentive is gone
you spend those years doing something
else and that accounts for some of it as
well there have been a variety of ways
in which in which the acts of taking
responsibility for your spouse and your
children used to confer a lot of status
on you because when you did get married
in 19 and 22 the father of to the to the
mother of your children you were doing
the right thing and it was seen by the
community as the right thing sure and
that status has pretty much disappear
as far as I can tell yeah yeah I want I
want to switch to another topic that I
have to raise because I imprudently
co-wrote a book on IQ some years ago 22
years ago called the bell curve and in
the bell curve we went to great lengths
to document the relationships of IQ to a
variety of personal characteristics such
as impulse control such as delayed
gratification the ability to calculate
and consider long-term consequences of
behavior now IQ is not a problem in the
vance family or your relatives on either
side of your parentage your mother was
apparently solid salya Taurean of her
class and this was in an age when there
weren't 25 salya torian's you know there
were only one or two so that's pretty
good and she also encouraged your
academics and and then you yourself
despite having not been a model student
perhaps during your school years
nonetheless managed not only graduate
and get pretty good test scores then get
into the marine corps and then get into
house estate and then get into Yale Law
School so I don't think you have an IQ
problem and and let's say that's true of
the family so therefore Nick Hern Stein
and I must emphasize IQ isn't everything
because because you you and the audience
you have not read the book have no idea
how crazy this family is in so many ways
in terms of all sorts of things that
happen and the case that that the
obvious case is that they were
financially doing quite well for a while
and and there were there were decisions
taken that made it extremely likely that
that financial security was going to go
away and a variety of other things so as
you've you've had to reflect upon this
in your own mind Here I am
the Yale Law degree out in Silicon
Valley
what what is the difference if it's not
native ability between you and the
others who made such very different
decisions well it's very it's very
tempting to sort of congratulate myself
and if everyone wants to tell me that I
have a high IQ then you're more than
welcome to do so
but I don't necessarily think that
that's that's what was really going on
and in my background and so I say that
for a couple reasons so one you know I
never felt like an idiot when I was a
kid I never felt like I was one of the
kids who really really struggled with
schoolwork but I also didn't feel much
more intelligent than most of the kids
that I grew up around I felt like yeah
sure I did fine maybe I was above
average but I certainly wasn't brilliant
and I remember thinking especially in in
my home town were not a whole lot of
kids go to Ivy League schools that the
people who went to these schools were
just unbelievably brilliant it's like
you know 200 Stephen Hawking's and I I
recognized about three days after I got
there that that's not actually the case
so so so to me the difference and you
know that there was this this very good
review that was of the book that was
somewhat critical where one of the
points that he made is the reviewer made
is look one of the things that JT Vance
benefits from is having natural innate
ability that a lot of other kids don't
have and again it's very sort of
tempting to back slap yourself on the
back and say great I was really smart
and that's why I made it but my sense is
that the people who didn't make it who
had grew up in similar circumstances
which was a lot of kids in my hometown
versus the kids who did is that they had
a couple of things one they had at least
one really strong male figure in their
lives and they had at least one really
strong female figure in their lives they
had a sort of maternal and paternal
presence even if that wasn't their mom
and dad right so for me that was my
grandpa and later my biological dad with
him I reconnected and of course Mamaw my
grandma who is this sort of force of
nature when she died actually we made a
CD of her favorite songs and we entitled
it force of nature because that's the
only thing that we could think of to
describe her and so it was this constant
Tim
station to make bad decisions to hang
out with the wrong crowd I mean when I
was a kid the first time I smoked pot I
was probably 11 or 12 and I remember the
kid who was encouraging me to smoke and
I don't think that I put this in the
book but I remember when my grandma
found out she would lean din and
whispered and said shady if you don't
stop hanging out with that kid I'm gonna
run them over with my car and no one is
gonna find out and I told you I told you
and I remember thinking I you know and
most people most kids ignore that that
you know parents tell kids not to hang
out with the bad kids all the time
but when my grandma said it I was like
oh my god maybe you know maybe I don't
want to get this guy killed so I'm gonna
stop and and and that was really
something that she that was her that
wasn't anything about me that wasn't
anything even about my family that was a
person who recognized that there were
temptations to bad decisions and she was
gonna prevent me from succumbing to this
temptation so I think that's a huge huge
part of it
yeah it's something that you referred to
there there were several things you
referred to I want to follow up on and
one of them is that you didn't really
spend much time thinking about how smart
you are when you were a kid yeah the
children of upper-middle class and
especially new upper-class parents spend
a great proportion of their time
worrying about how smart they are partly
because their parents keep telling them
you're so smart but but it is it is part
of the it's an integral part of who they
are not just an integral part but a
central part and that reminds me of the
experience that my wife and I have had
in this little town in Maryland where we
lived where the public high school there
were lots of really really bright kids
who weren't aware of how bright they
were and there was not the that nobody
was saying to them you know what you got
a free ride at Yale or Harvard or
Dartmouth Stanford if you nobody was
saying that to them - sure and it's and
the difference between that atmosphere
in a white working-class community
and the atmosphere in Potomac and Chevy
Chase and Northwest Washington is you
know vast the the other thing that I
want to follow up on with that is your
experience at Yale because you've to say
you discovered that you got there and
they weren't all geniuses after all talk
a little bit more about that and here
and and and and the reaction of the kid
from Middletown ex-marine Corps
infantryman getting to Yale yeah well I
I think the sense that to make it to an
Ivy League school you had to be a genius
was so powerful and so strong in my own
life that I really expected to show up
and for everyone to realize oh you know
the the admissions officer drank a
little bit too much bourbon she was
looking at this at this application but
you know again was sort of surprised to
realize that what really set the kids at
Yale Law School apart from you know
other people that I've interacted with
is it yeah sure they were certainly
above-average intelligence they were
very smart but they were extraordinarily
hard-working and very ambitious right so
they were willing to put in these
insanely long hours in the library in a
way that was just completely foreign to
me if I hadn't joined the Marine Corps
you know I remember the first sort of
20-hour work day that I put in the
Marine Corps and I couldn't believe it
but these kids at Yale I thought of as
really coddled the one thing that we're
really willing to do was lose sleep in
order to get ahead in classroom or in
some other way so that was definitely a
huge difference I mean there is I think
a cult of innate ability that we have in
in you know the upper class and in the
lower class I'd say broadly in sort of
American culture because I remember it
was the the day that I asked my wife's
father permission to propose to her we
just went golfing we're eating breakfast
and I was talking about you know her she
went to Yale and Yale Law School and her
sister is also very smart and
accomplished and I was like how did you
it raised these really smart kids
they're just unbelievable and you know
these are first-generation immigrant
from India and he was like they're not
very smart they're just hard-working and
I couldn't believe it because
where I'm from my family thinks that my
wife is this like otherworldly genius
and I do too but to you know that there
is this sense I mean of course she's
very very smart but even in her own
family it was more about work than it
was about about innate ability so I
think it's it's not necessarily always
true I certainly think my wife is is
much smarter than the gross majority of
folks I've interacted with in my life
certainly much smarter than I am but one
thing that she's really you know one
thing that is true is that she works
harder than anybody I've ever met I I
agree with all you've said but there's
also another side to that coin
that I recall from when my wife and I
were working on a book about the Apollo
program and one of the people in Mission
Control was saying you know this the
stuff you're doing with IQ is way
overblown it's you know I I didn't go
anywhere until I had motivation and once
I got motivation that's made all the
difference and I said no is it I said
Jerry do you happen to know what your IQ
is yeah it's a hundred forty-six
motivation really helps there's another
thing there's another lead on the Yale
business though that that fascinates
because one of the other themes of my
work is the kids at Yale too many of
them haven't a clue about Middletown
sure they haven't clue about white
working-class America they haven't a
clue about mainstream America and what I
want you to do of course is to give me
several vivid illustrations of why I'm
exactly right but you get my drift yeah
yeah no that's definitely true I mean
there's there's obviously a huge
cultural disconnect and if you didn't
think that there was then just look at
the 2016 election of course yeah and and
you know one of the things that was very
that when I realized that this cultural
disconnect was very real I was in a
class it was a national security class I
believe of or at least had some national
security connection and one of the
students after learning that I was in
the Marine Corps before I went to law
school asked me she was kind of
surprised and like you went to you went
to the Marines you were in the Marine
Corps
and I was like yeah yeah why is that so
surprising and her response was like I
just didn't know that people who joined
the military were like you you know
we're nice were like that and I remember
at the time thinking huh that's an
interesting comment to make but but but
but I definitely you know that there is
you know a very remarkable cultural
disconnect between that part of the
world and the part in the world that I
grew up in and you know it never really
affected me in a negative way in law
school I mean I you know there's
certainly a lot of stories in the book
about how I didn't quite know how to
navigate the elite world of via Law
School you know the first time that I
had a really really fancy dinner
I didn't know how what to do with the
utensils so I excused myself to call my
wife and say what do I do with why why
are there two butter knives you don't
even need one you can just use your
finger tell me what to do with these
things and you know she of course guided
me through that a lot of similar
experiences but you know there was
definitely just a sense that the people
don't quite understand anything it goes
both directions right I mean the people
that I grew up around don't quite
understand the elites and the elites
don't quite understand the people that I
grew up around the difference being that
the elites are the ones who make
decisions that affect the lives of
people Middletown nice people in
Middletown don't listen uh you may have
mentioned the election and I'm going to
ask you one last question before we go
to the audience because in this election
cycle we have had the white
working-class be a huge story source of
support for Donald Trump and we have
also had race be an enormous story and
you are kind of a unique observer
resource you I don't know what the
racial makeup was of Middletown or the
rest of your life that you've observed
the white working-class you've observed
in the marine corps race relations
you've been at a large public university
and you have been at Yale Law School the
most to lead to the most elite and in
all of those four areas I imagined that
the issue of race and the way the people
talk about it and the way people think
about it
has to be different and maybe in some
ways the same and I just love to hear
you reflect on that yeah so my takeaway
from sort of my life especially my time
at Yale Law School is that everyone
probably is pretty prejudiced and that
if you don't want to be prejudiced you
have to sort of recognize it and fight
against it I just think the prejudice
operates at different levels from back
home and a law school so a big question
is like how much is racial anxiety drive
the Trump phenomenon and my answer this
question I'm asked is I think it drives
some of it I don't think that it's the
main thing but I definitely think it's
it's something that's going on but you
know people yellow school are still
pretty prejudiced and if you're doesn't
manifest itself well let's say you don't
know a single Trump motor in your life
but you say that about a Trump voter
he's the racist candidate but all these
racist rednecks deserve right I think
that's a form of prejudice and it's a
form of prejudice yeah it's a form of
prejudice that is extraordinarily real
and that people back home feel very very
passionate about right so my grandma
once told me like I put this in the book
but Hillbillies are the only group of
people that the media that you know the
elites that's not in terms she would
have ever used they're the only group of
people you're still allowed to make fun
of in polite company and it wasn't an
excuse that you should be able to make
fun of all the other people it was her
saying there's something weird about the
fact that we still say redneck or
hillbilly in the way that we that a lot
of people use it and that there's not
even a little bit of Paul's about that
now of course that's not an argument
that it you know we should go around
using racial slurs but it is I think a
recognition that what exists in some of
these elite enclaves is a certain amount
of seclusion from people like my grandma
and a failure to recognize that you're
pretty biased against them a lot of
times even though you don't recognize it
and so one of the things I've tried to
do since the book has come out is sort
of you know recognize that a lot of the
people who hear me talk they see me as
this sort of representative of the
appalachian or the white working-class
voter and my hope is that when they hear
me speak they don't have all their worst
lassis confirmed
I think that you are safe and not
worrying about that I'm going to go to
the audience now and we have I assume
microphones that can be taken around yes
we do and I see a hand up right the
gentleman with the beard standing up
right now thank you for being here a
very interesting presentation I grew up
in Cleveland Ohio in the in the 50s
early 60s and of course Cleveland was in
some ways a larger scale of of
Middletown very heavily industrialized
very heavily unionized strongly
Democratic and with a lot of folks that
had moved up after the war from West
Virginia the hillbillies as we
disparagingly called them at that time
but even at that time you could see the
early signs of the industrialization
that took place particularly terms
because of the heavy unionization the
work rules the tax laws at that time
that worked against industrial water do
that we do need a question right my
question is to what extent did you see
even when you were kid did you see those
same processes at work in Middletown and
a follow-up question when I was a kid
Middletown was a great basketball
powerhouse Jerry Lucas I thought was the
role of athletics plus-or-minus in
Middletown from your experience yeah so
don't I probably can't speak very well
to the role of athletics plus-or-minus
so I do think that it gives people some
measure of social capital something to
gather around about and I think
athletics it's still a very big deal in
Middletown our basketball team isn't
quite as good as it was in the Jerry
Lucas days but still sports is something
that that's very important to Middletown
I mean the question about what to what
degree I sort of solved the
industrialisation going on I think the
only answer I can give is that I saw it
but I didn't quite realize what I was
seeing you know I certainly realized
that maybe there weren't as many open
store fronts that maybe there were some
businesses that were going out of
business and I definitely recognized
that there was a problem
you know maybe not quite as many people
were
able to get Armco jobs but that was
something I sort of recognized when I
was much older you know as a six or
seven year old kid I think the writing
was on the wall but I just didn't
necessarily see it and it really hit me
I will never forget it was I believe
right after I came home from Iraq in
2006 a case steal which would be Armco
steal had become a KC Elvis Kawasaki had
bought it
there was a labor lockout and it was the
first time that there had been a labor
lockout I believe since my grandpa had
been a pretty young worker at that steel
mill and that was when it really hit me
that some of these economic pressures
were hitting Middletown in a very real
way the last thing I'll say is that
Middletown by some standards has been
really lucky you know it's not you know
dying in the way that lets say
Youngstown or Detroit is it still
suffers from a lot of
deindustrialization problems but it's in
some ways it's lucky because a case
steal is still around which is something
that probably most you know steel mill
workers can't say that my mill is still
there toward the front right here I want
to press you a little bit on causality
because you know we've taught you you
obviously have this picture of this very
sharp and pretty recent and pretty
market decline that everyone you know
can kind of take a snapshot up and you
say kind of pointedly here and you've
also said in the book it's an its
economic but a little bit of is it
economic and and and Charles has a
theory that's kind of about it's really
goes back to a sort of very clear
marriage that then had consequences how
do you put it all together what the what
the biggest factors of causality are I
mean I kind of heard you saying people
not resisting a change in culture but I
still don't quite hear a theory of
causality yeah I mean that I think it's
a very fair point because one of the
things that I don't necessarily do a lot
of the book is try to have a theory of
causality
it's maybe lurking in the background but
I'm much more interested in sort of you
know what are the things that are going
on in the hope that they can provide
some measure of an idea of what the
solutions might be whether they're
economic or policy or cultural whatever
you want to say you know my sense is
that the the most underappreciated part
of the causality story is the way that
religion has changed in these
communities
it's not it doesn't just operate at the
level of family pressure but you know
one of the things that Charles really
you know made me realize in the book
coming apart is that religion
traditional religious practices decline
in these these communities but you know
one of the things I write about is that
it's declined but there is still a very
weird way that religion is operating
right it's the people aren't going to
church as much but they still identify
as conservative evangelical Christians
they still wear their faith as a sort of
badge of honor and my guess is that a
lot of these trends and traditional
religious practice from the mega church
- the church relocating to upper-middle
cut in [ __ ] communities - even
substantive things like the prosperity
gospel is really operating on these
communities in a way that it's not the
whole story it's may not maybe not even
most of the story but the more I think
about it the more I think that the
decline of traditional religious
practice is probably the least
appreciated part of this problem
interesting in the front row here by the
way if you'd say your name and
affiliation please yes my name is kami
Burton with the Pakistani Spectator and
my question is that why it's so rare to
hear or read something about poverty
among whites in America I've been in the
city for more than 30 years and we
always listen about poverty among blacks
poverty among Latino and poverty about
other minorities but this is the very
rare chance that we are listening about
poverty among whites and this is
understood since majority of the people
are white in this country so in absolute
numbers there are more white poorer than
blacks or any other minority and is that
because media happened to be very elite
and then the same context does media
hate Donald Trump because he talks about
blue-collar whites why people so are a
logic of this white poverty topic and is
that the only reason they hate Donald
Trump because he talked about average
person Thanks I I've taken a personal
pledge not to say the word Donald Trump
from now until the election so I'm sure
that I can't make good on it but let me
comment a little bit about the brunt of
your question that the largest single
group of ethnic group of poor people in
this country or whites I do think that
an awful lot of what we have seen in the
last year is the sense of the white
working-class of what about us that
there has been so much attention paid to
a variety of very serious and very real
problems that affect ethnic minorities
and and women and it's not just a white
working class it's the white
working-class male who is saying you
know what am I chopped liver and it's
worse than that because you talk about
the way that you can dent one of the few
slurs you can use at a polite Georgetown
dinner party and get no pushback is
redneck but you can also say all sorts
of things about males that are really
awful
some of them true but you say a lot of
awful things about males that aren't
true and you don't get any pushback from
that either there's a really strong
sense of everybody dumps on us and and
then they go out and say we have to
check our privilege you know and and I
think that anger is visceral and real
and it is a consequence in large part of
what they see every day in as the
priorities of interest when they watch
TV and read the newspapers you wouldn't
want to add anything to it yeah I mean
the only Shore thing I agree with with
with that the only real thing that I
would add is that why does the media not
talk about it so much and my guess is
just that white poverty isn't
politically meaningful right so the poor
you are you're less likely to vote if
you're sort of struggling working-class
you've been sort of the you know the
property of the Republican Party for the
past thirty years they have consistently
voted with rare exceptions for the
Republicans so I think maybe it takes a
sort of political moment or some other
way of expression for you know the media
to wake up to some of these problems
it's my guess yeah okay I'm gonna go to
the center here and then I'll go over to
the right
John Quin Snyder read Zima photo I'd
like to ask Charles Marie something in
parallel to what you've been talking
about about the the elite in this
country not understanding what's going
on in white working-class America twice
this year in March you spoke to college
on college campuses of Virginia Tech and
then Williams College and in the case of
Virginia Tech before you got there the
president wrote an open letter which you
very properly and quite frankly
plain-spoken Lee refuted about what your
work means at Williams College after
you've spoken there the college
newspaper characterized your your work
again in a way which misrepresents it
and I wonder in both cases did you get
the sense when you spoke to those
college communities that anybody was
listening to you oh yeah they look at
Virginia Tech there were half a dozen of
aging meaning they were close to my age
aging faculty members with signs and
inside the hall were some hundreds of
mostly students who listened to
tentatively and asked two questions same
thing as true of the Williams College
appearance I think that one of the
underappreciated things is the degree to
which a lot of the idiocy on colleges
college campuses is a driven by
relatively small minorities of the
faculty especially in social sciences
and humanities and driven by relatively
small minorities of students in the
social sciences and the humanities and
the end that once you get outside those
fields you have a lot of people who are
intimidated by the atmosphere that has
been created but I think they're being
held hostage and so I welcome all chance
to speak in college campuses cuz I have
good experiences when I go there if I
just ignore the idiots yes over here and
this will have to be I'm afraid our last
question make it a good one John Graham
National Center for Policy Analysis
thank you very much my question is about
the insularity of the ivy
League class and I think it's changed so
my father was a stockbroker and my
mother was a lecturer but when I was a
teenager I bag groceries at the
supermarket and my peers all did the
same and we knew we were going to
university we knew but that developing
that work ethic was as important to
studying and I get the sense that the
Ivy League students of today haven't had
that experience and they were younger is
is that true that's by and large my
experience I think it's very true and in
some ways the way that I would I would
describe this is that there was a sense
that among this class of people life was
a race and the goal of parents was to
give as much of a leg up in that race as
humanly possible and unfortunately
bagging groceries doesn't do nearly as
much if you're trying to get ahead in
that race as for pairing kids for the
SAT so I definitely think there's some
some a lot of elements truth to that
I'll just add that I think that's hugely
important I have a quiz the bubble quiz
that I put in coming apart and that
since has been online that says how
thick is your bubble that isolates you
from mainstream America and and the most
important question I think in the 25 is
have you ever held a job that caused a
body part to hurt at the end of the day
even if even if it's just your feet
aching from standing up behind a counter
because if you have never held such a
job you're sort of fundamentally unable
to empathize with the huge chunk of
America who all those jobs every day and
more importantly than that you've you
have a distorted sense of what work is
that that separates you I think very
fundamentally from the rest of the
country well I can't say first how much
I enjoyed the book it is a wonderful
read that is not just saying nice things
and Jade jd's behalf it is terrific and
I urge all of you to go get a copy if
you don't have one and and read it
immediately and and jdu in person have
been as engaging and and insightful as
you were in the book it's been a
pleasure thank you
[Music]
[Applause]